estuve revisando esto del problema 142
que se me hizo muy extraño se me hizo
muy extraño porque los que hicieron el
libro de heymann
dijeron que el inciso 2 no era
suficiente para responder y yo no estoy
de acuerdo con eso pero déjame
recordarte un poco como estaba la cosa
en este problema lo que nos pedían bueno
lo que nos decían es que x era un entero
x es entero
entero y lo que nos pedían determinar
era sí 9 a la x 9 a la x + 9 a la menos
x es igual a b es igual a b y había un
inciso 1 que decía que 3 a la x 3 a la x
+ 3 a la menos x es igual a raíz de 2 b
es igual a raíz la raíz perdón de 2tb +
2 b
+ 2 muy bien ahora en el vídeo pasado
dije que este inciso servía para
responder esta pregunta para determinar
si esto era cierto y en eso sigo
totalmente de acuerdo si sirve para
responderlo lo voy a poner palomita lo
que hacíamos era elevar al cuadrado y
después hacer un poco de cuentas pero en
el que no estoy tan de acuerdo ahora es
en el inciso 2 en el inciso 2 nos decían
que x es mayor que 0 que es igual a b y
entonces en el vídeo pasado dije que la
respuesta era a que la respuesta era a
que únicamente el inciso 1 servía para
responder esta pregunta pero yo digo que
no yo digo que también la el inciso 2
nos ayuda a responder si esto es cierto
o no es cierto el chiste no es llegar a
que esto sea verdadero sino a poder
responder si esto es verdadero y más o
menos lo que hicimos la vez pasada fue
un poco complicado pero más o menos
podemos decirlo de la siguiente forma
imagínate que sabemos que b es igual a 0
es decir la información del inciso 2
entonces tendríamos una cosa del estilo
9 a la x + 9 a la menos x es igual a 0
pero si lo pensamos tantito esto de aquí
es imposible porque porque 9 a la x
siempre va a ser un número positivo y 9
a la menos x también va a ser un número
positivo entonces esta suma siempre nos
tiene que dar un número positivo incluso
aunque permitamos que algunos de estos
numeritos sea menos infinito pues de
todas formas nos va a dar algo muy
grande por ejemplo si no es y aquí
tenemos 9 a la menos infinito que sería
la única forma en la cual es posible que
uno de estos suman 2 nos dé 0 entonces
el otro sumando sería 9 a la infinito
que sería un sumando grandísimo y
entonces la suma no podría dar 0 esto de
9 a la menos infinito simplemente es 1
entre 9 a la infinito vale o sea 9 a la
x + 9 a la menos x no hay que
confundirse este menos no nos da un
signo menos aquí afuera simplemente hace
que esto sea 9 a la equis
+ 1 / 9 a la equis el inverso
multiplicativo o el recíproco entonces
bueno si este número de acá es muy muy
muy muy grande estoy acá es muy muy
cercano a 0 pero positivo y entonces
pues este número no va a poder ser 0 si
la x es muy cercana a 0 este es muy
cercano a 1 y este también entonces la
suma sería como 2
tampoco sirve y vaya de cualquier forma
que intentemos hacerlo no vamos a poder
conseguir 0 entonces esto de aquí nunca
nunca es igual a 0 y por lo tanto esto
de aquí nunca puede ser igual a b porque
en este caso b es igual a 0
de esta forma la información del inciso
2 nos permite responder esta pregunta
negativamente pero de todas formas nos
permite responderla vale entonces cómo
podemos responderla este inciso también
es información suficiente y por lo tanto
la respuesta sería b
la respuesta sería d espero no estar
haciendo nada extraño oa lo mejor
simplemente es como algún error de
tipografía o algo así pero cualquiera de
estas 2
tenemos así nos permiten responder esta
pregunta vale bueno ahora vamos a pasar
al problema 143
problemas 143 en el problema 143 nos
dicen que m es mayor que 0 m es mayor
que 0 que n es mayor que 0 mn son
mayores que 0 y lo que tenemos que
determinar es si m x / n x m
+ x / n x
/ n más x es mayor que m / n mayor que m
/ n
muy bien vamos a analizar un poquito
esta expresión para intentar agarrar un
poco de intuición antes de responder por
ejemplo qué sucedería si me fuera 1 y n
fuera 2 aquí tendríamos un medio y aquí
tendríamos un medio pero además están
estas equis en estas equis de aquí
entonces si aquí fuera muy grande como
20 tendríamos 21 entre 22 si x fuera
1000 tendríamos 1000 1 entre 1000 2 esta
fracción se acerca cada vez más y más a
uno a lo mejor has visto eso en sus
clases de límites sale entonces si
hacemos hacer la equis tender a infinito
o que sea muy muy grande esta fracción
se va a acercar mucho a uno pero no sé
si eso vaya a ayudar déjame ver qué
información nos dan en los incisos en el
inciso 1
en el inciso 1 nos dicen que m es menor
que en que m es menor que en ok entonces
m es menor que n de forma que esta
fracción m entre n es menor que 1
ahora como te dije si le sumamos cosas y
si le sumamos cosas positivas entonces
esto va a estar más cerca de 1 que esta
fracción pero quién sabe a lo mejor la
equis es negativa verdad entonces no sé
vamos a dar algunos ejemplos si m es
igual a 4 y n es igual a 5 y tenemos no
sé x es igual a 1 entonces esta fracción
sería cuatro quintos y estaría acá sería
cinco cuartos y tenemos que 5 15 sextos
verdad 5 sextos le gana a cuatro quintos
entonces aquí la respuesta sería así
pero qué sucede si x es negativo si x es
igual a menos 1 tendríamos tendríamos
que comparar
tres cuartos 3
cuartos
contra contra cuatro quintos
y tendríamos que ver si tres cuartos es
mayor que cuatro quintos pero no verdad
tres cuartos es más pequeño que cuatro
quintos cuatro quintos está simplemente
a un quinto de uno y tres cuartos está a
un cuarto de uno entonces pues no está
de acá nos da la desigualdad volteada y
por lo tanto esta información por sí
misma no es suficiente para responder
esta pregunta vamos al inciso 2 en el
inciso 2 nos dicen que x es mayor que 0
x es mayor que 0 ok a ver x es mayor que
0 vamos a ver si esta información por sí
misma es suficiente otra vez déjame
agarrar este ejemplo oa lo mejor debería
agarrar uno al revés pues vamos a ver
qué pasa
voy a ponerle x es igual a 1 y vamos a
ponerle m
4 y n igual a 5 en este de acá ya vimos
que 5 sextos lo que queda a la izquierda
si es mayor si es mayor que cuatro
quintos entonces aquí si se da la
desigualdad ahora qué sucede si volteo
la m y la n por qué está esta condición
no restringe eso si x es igual a 1
m es igual a 5 y n es igual a 4 y n es
igual a 4 bueno en este caso la fracción
que tendríamos a la izquierda sería 6
quintos y lo que tenemos que ver es si 6
quintos le gana a 5 cuartos a 5 cuartos
pero estás acá no es cierta verdad 6
quintos es uno más un quinto y cinco
cuartos es uno más un cuarto entonces
este un cuarto es más que un quinto por
lo tanto el lado derecho sería más
grande entonces esta desigualdad va al
revés va al revés y por lo tanto tenemos
las dos opciones así que este inciso por
sí solito no nos permite responder lo
que queremos no nos permite saber si
esta desigualdad se da o no pero ahora
sí si los juntamos yo digo que sí por
qué porque si tenemos cualquier valor de
mn no se toma el ejemplo que tú quieras
siempre y cuando m sea menor que en por
ejemplo seis octavos si tenemos seis
octavos y le vamos sumando cosas
positivas de aquí pasaríamos por ejemplo
a siete novenos que está más cercano a
uno por lo tanto es más grande
si le sumamos otro uno pasaríamos a ocho
decimos que está todavía más cerca de
uno si le tomamos si le sumamos otro
serían nueve onceavos y cada vez nos
acercamos más más a uno y por lo tanto
tenemos que estos números son más y más
grandes porque nos acercamos a uno por
abajo vale entonces juntando los dos si
podemos responder esta pregunta y de
hecho la respondemos afirmativamente de
modo que la respuesta sería c
muy bien problemas 144 problemas 144
en el problema 144 nos dicen que en ese
entero positivo es entero
entero positivo positivo
y lo que tenemos que determinar es si un
décimo a la n
un décimo a la n es menor menor que cero
punto cero 10.01 es simplemente un
décimo al cuadrado entonces lo que
tenemos que ver es es si un décimo a la
n es menor que un 10º 11º al cuadrado lo
cual sucede cuando bueno vamos a ver las
opciones mejor vale un décimo a la n
menor que un décimo al cuadrado entonces
en la opción 1 en la opción 1 nos dicen
que en es mayor que 2 n es mayor que 2
ok si n es mayor que 2 que le sucede a
este número que le sucede a un décimo
cuando lo elevamos a potencias más y más
grandes pues justo se va haciendo más y
más pequeño verdad por ejemplo un décimo
al cubo sería 0.001
y esto de aquí es menor que 0.01 pues sí
verdad qué pasa si lo elevamos a la
cuarta sería 0.0001 esto de aquí es
menor que 0.01 pues también de hecho en
este caso no importa qué valor de n
pongamos si queda que el de la izquierda
es menor verdad porque un décimo es un
número menor que uno y entonces un
décimo a la n es menor que uno entre
diez al cuadrado esto lo puedes
verificar multiplicando cruzado 10 al
cuadrado menor
que 10 a la n cuando n es mayor que 2
entonces la información del inciso 1 si
es suficiente vamos a ver qué dice el
inciso 2 en el inciso 2 nos dicen que un
décimo a la n 1 undécimo
a la n 1 es menor que 0.1 menor que 0.1
ok pues aquí podemos multiplicar por un
décimo de ambos lados para obtener un
décimo a la n a la izquierda entonces
aquí tendríamos un décimo a la n iv
queremos y nos están diciendo que eso es
menor que 0.1 por un décimo o sea que
0.01 entonces la información del inciso
2 justo se reduce a lo que queremos
probar a responder esta pregunta vale
entonces la información del inciso 2
también es suficiente por sí misma y de
este modo la respuesta sería b b muy
bien vamos a dejarle hasta aquí y nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo